we have 52 people on the team now if you
ask me how many people on my team I say
I don't know 10. and like really who and
then I look at the list like oh yeah
because I'm not in all the stuff and and
I just forget and then the next thought
was 52 people that's crazy but if I
believe that it's crazy then how am I
gonna get the 500 people and it's just
always trying to catch the language and
the thought patterns that we tell
ourselves because I think most of it is
subconscious and so whether you can
catch it in yourself or when somebody
else calls you out that you say no 52
people that's not crazy Evan three
whatever million subscribers we have
cool that's great and like how do we get
to 35 really what does that look like
nobody's done it garyvee and Tony
Robbins and Mel Robbins and Marie forleo
and Les Brown and whoever and you put
them all together you're still not at 35
million subscribers so how do I get
there and it feels impossible but as
long as it feels impossible then it is
impossible I mean I think the world's
biggest problems people don't believe in
themselves because there is no box it's
like you can just why I do what I do is
I hope that a video that I make whether
it's like this story with you or a less
ground interview or whatever that's like
that's the moment that somebody watches
it and realizes oh there's no I could
just walk there's no door I'm not tied
to anything need motivation watch the
top 10 with believe Nation Hey Kevin
Carmichael and I make these videos
because as a young entrepreneur I
struggle to keep my business going I had
no friends I had no mentors I had no
role models and the thing that saved me
was learning from the success stories of
famous entrepreneurs and in their
stories I got motivation and I also got
strategies for what I could do to grow
my business and not stay stuck and I
still need their stories motivation
today so today let's learn from me and
my team's take on my top 10 rules for
Success enjoy
rule number two is Embrace change
everything in your life will change when
you realize that you do not want an easy
life stop praying for easy stop praying
for convenience you don't want it
because you don't want to photocopy your
life every single day over and over and
over and over again you want variety you
want change you want something different
but with that variety comes uncertainty
comes pain comes challenges and from
that pain comes purpose ultimately your
purpose comes from your pain and the
more pain you go through the more
challenges you take on the more you
stretch yourself in your comfort zone
the more you're going to be able to
reach down and help somebody come up to
your level as well you can only help
people to the extent that you have been
through something so the next time
you're going through some pain tell
yourself this is the best because it's
your chance to show yourself and the
world What You're Made Of and will
Define the impact that you will have
rule number three is Adopt a healthy
lifestyle this morning I did my walk
outside I did my yoga I did my my stairs
with the cold I'm gonna try a couple
things one I'm going to try wearing
fewer layers when I go outside it's
becoming winter here in Canada and it
gets really cold in winter in Canada so
I'm gonna try to embrace that a little
bit more and wear fewer layers two I do
a cold Splash every morning so one of
the first things I do when I wake up is
is I just put a whole bunch of cold
water all over my face so I'm gonna keep
doing that and then three after every
workout a cold shower so I did it this
morning after my yoga workout this
morning turned on the cold went in
making sure to get it on the backs of
the shoulder this is from Tim Ferriss
that's where the the brown fat really
lives and comes alive and so making sure
you get the cold water on the backs your
shoulder the book also quickly mentions
cryotherapy where you stand in the
machine and it takes you down to some
crazy low temperature I'm pretty sure he
said that it didn't have a ton of
research or he wasn't sure how well it
worked but he did it once so you know
what I'm gonna look into it too the goal
of this today challenge is that how much
can I do in 50 days to expose myself to
learn to get ideas to get mentors so I'm
going to also look up cryotherapy in my
town and see if I can find something for
me it is 3 24 p.m I am officially
fasting until 6 pm
6p this is a lifesaver
[Music]
but you know what a little bit of
Himalayan sea salt and I'm good I'm good
these next two and a half hours no
problem we got this okay it is 6 30. I
get to eat
um we're doing a buffet for my
father-in-law's birthday so Pro side is
gonna be lots of hopefully some healthy
food for me to eat down inside is seeing
all of the amazing other stuff that I
can't eat
but it's okay let's go
[Music]
this is Nina's meal
rule number four is eliminate negative
thoughts imagine that 80 of the thoughts
that you've got eighty percent
are negative we are beating ourselves up
we are telling ourselves that we can't
do things it's not even our friends and
family the people around us telling us
that we suck it's us it's ourselves we
tell ourselves we're not good enough we
can't do this we're not strong enough
smart enough we're from the wrong
country we look the wrong way you know
we're too young we're too old whatever
it is 80 of our thoughts are negative
and then 95 of those negative thoughts
are the exact same negative thoughts
that we had yesterday it's no wonder why
we stay small it's no wonder why we stay
stuck because we've created this
reinforcing Loop of negativity this is
why I think the world's biggest problem
is lack of belief you know I'm I'm on a
mission every day wake up try to make
content try to spread the message to
help people believe in themselves more I
think lack of belief is the single
biggest problem in the world and I also
believe that everybody has Michael
Jordan level genius as something like
you are the greatest you're the greatest
in the world at something and it's not
what you went to school for and it's not
what your parents did for living
probably is something completely
different and you have to have the
courage to go off and Chase it and find
it and and do it because
the woman who solves cancer should have
already solved it by now but she never
believed in herself enough to go to
medical school and now she's a manager
and accounting firm which doesn't like
her life right I mean this is this is
where most of us are stuck most people
wake up and they drive the job that that
we don't like most people are stuck and
barely hanging on and do not like their
life and feel like they're not
contributing they're not they're not
making any kind of difference they're
not doing anything meaningful or
impactful at all in the world that's
most people I can imagine waking up and
that's your daily reality that may be
you or that may have been who you were
and you still Discover it and trying to
improve and get better but if 80 of
those thoughts that come through your
head conscious or unconscious are
negative I think a lot of conscious
thoughts are negative too
not just the subconscious the conscious
thoughts are negative you telling
yourself that you can't do something and
you're not good enough and then 95
percent are the same as yesterday that
we've just created this this Loop this
negative thinking Loop also to make sure
you're actually taking action after
watching this video I've designed a
special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the Lessons Learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five is serve others I
want to hit more people I want to serve
more people like people I want to spread
the message I believe and word the one
there is like it's so possible and
people need this so much and like how do
I make that happen what is it that
people need
that you are bringing to them what is
the problem that you were solving and
for who yeah I think the biggest problem
Humanity faces is a lack of belief
I think in themselves themselves yeah
it's like I think whatever cancer should
have been solved a decade ago but the
woman who would have solved cancer as a
manager at KPMG doing a job because she
never believed in herself enough right
that's my like we solve solve
self-belief you solve every other
problem in the world I have a bias
towards entrepreneurs because that's who
I love helping the most so that would be
like helping entrepreneurs believe
themselves more not that you know
teachers in government than whoever else
can't do it I know your background is
like corporate stuff as well it's like
great corporations have a huge role to
play I just default to entrepreneurs but
the problem I'm trying to solve is
helping people believe in themselves
more I think the way to do that is
content at scale people get to learn
from you today and learn to have more
self-belief even though like one-on-one
time with you would be insanely
expensive but my journey hopefully they
can learn a little bit as well through
this session so that's what I'm trying
to solve and for who rule number six is
stay present hey if you're
present-minded you're going to be be a
lot happier you're going to be a lot
more focused right if you're just
thinking about what you should have done
or what might happen to you you're not
actually able to be productive and get
stuff out right now in the present and
so the job becomes how do I stay present
and I think a lot of that is
accomplished through meditation for most
people if you're if you're in a state of
stress thinking about the regret of the
past or anxiety about the future I think
meditation can be incredibly helpful to
help you get back to present even just
focusing on your breath breathe in
breathe out even something as simple as
that can help calm me down and get you
back to the present moment which then
allows you to
be able to be productive solve the
problem be happy because you're being
more present so for me that's actually
quite easy I'm in the present uh a lot
more than anywhere else and I used to
think it as a negative a friend of mine
used to make fun of me for having a bad
memory it's like you're such a bad
memory it's like and I later realized I
I don't have a bad memory I I one
remember what's important to me but two
I'm not living in the past like I don't
care about what happened I'm looking at
right now today I don't know what day it
is I don't know what day it is I don't
know I I know it's 2022 when recording
this I'd have to think about what month
it is
I don't know what I'm doing after
recording this video I don't know what I
did yesterday I don't know what I'm
doing tomorrow let alone once I press
stop on this video I am here with you
this is this is my entire attention is
making this video right now that's it
this is this is the present moment for
me and what I've discovered is
this is meditation
at least the the portion of it where
you're getting back to present moment if
that's one of the main benefits of
meditation then this is meditation for
me I'm only in the present moment right
now being here talking with you guys and
that's it
and I realize that most of my life is
lived like that yes I love planning for
where I'm gonna go but most of my time
isn't spent in planning it's in in
executing in doing and I have to look at
my calendar to see what I'm doing
tomorrow or what I'm doing when somebody
asks me on a Wednesday what's your
weekend gonna look like
weekend I don't even know what I'm doing
in the next hour let alone what I'm
doing this weekend and when people ask
me on a Monday how was your weekend like
I don't know
that was that was that was yesterday
that was two days ago I'm I got stuff to
do right now I'm working on my life
right now and and not just work even
just enjoying even just life even just
me spending time with with my wife or my
son or on a trip it's like let's enjoy
this moment where we're at right now and
so if that's you I would introduce the
idea of hey that's a different
perspective shift like maybe you are
meditating right now and you might be
over judging yourself because if you're
in the present that's one of the biggest
benefits rule number seven is improve
your sleep I used to Pivot watch and it
tracks my sleep and it gives me a score
every day for how well I slept and I've
hit I think 89 out of 100 as my best
sleep score and what I would love to do
is to improve my sleep school one of the
best things that happened to wearables
you have something that you can track so
I want to find a way to consistently be
in the 90s and have an excellent amazing
world-class sleep
so on the on the first day that I was
tracking that I did not use earplugs I
got an 88 sleep score which is pretty
good already up there
uh when I moved to the I don't have it
anymore through them away but I had the
kind of black just ones I think I showed
earlier in this video uh very standard
just kind of running the mill black
earphone they didn't do anything I got
an 80 sleep score but they were barely
in it wasn't really pulling anything
um any of the the audio out then I went
to the hardcore ones and these ones are
amazing these are the ones that I wore
at the Tony Robbins event that I was
right up against the speaker and it
really pulled it out so if you want a
good earplug whether for sleeping or not
the brand is called Heroes Heroes but
with an A so like Heroes there's only
one left in this pack extreme protection
earplugs 14 pairs and rr33 I think that
means something uh these are amazing
knocking out the sound so on the first
day I got an 84. so nothing no ear plugs
was 88 black ear plugs kind of standard
ear plugs got an 80. these earplugs went
up to 84 so we're going the right
direction on the first night on the
second night though it actually fell
down to 73.
uh what happened was I had this in and
when I was sleeping it caught on the
side and it jammed further into my ear
and it hurt and it woke me up so it
didn't have as good as sleep and so I
decided you know I'm not gonna wear it
I'm not gonna wear it the next day and
and I haven't I haven't gone back to it
so overall I don't think earplugs are
the solution for me so I'm not gonna
ongoing be using these I think the main
reason is I don't mind ambient noises
you know if something uh something broke
or something fell or there's a loud
noise a crash bang I'm gonna wake up but
overall I kind of like the ambient
noises it's kind of like you know a a
sleeping machine with the white noise or
I used to fall asleep listen to sports
radio at night I like having a little
bit of noise going on so the earplugs
are not helping me improve my Sleep
Quality I don't think they're hurting
except when it germs into my ear and it
causes a lot of pain so I don't think
it's hurting but I don't think it's
helping me rule number eight is be
disciplined discipline is your missing
ingredient you've got the heart you've
got the care you've got the desire to
serve you know you could be doing more
you want to do it for the right reasons
you're not just here to make money
you're here to have an impact in the
grow and do amazing things you know you
can do amazing things what's missing
discipline
there's just a lack of follow-through
it's the constant start and stop and
start and stop and start and stop and
for me there's nothing more
not just frustrating but sad than seeing
somebody who's got so much talent and so
much potential and so much of a heart
and just seeing them not win because
they're not following through because
you're just not doing the consistent
enough work that you're motivated and
inspired and then and then you're not
anymore and nothing happens and
one of the only things that saved me the
only one of the only reasons why I'm
here
making these videos and you're watching
and I've had any you know success in
social media is because I just was
disciplined that I just kept making
videos one of the things I love sharing
is my journey of YouTube because I was
not an overnight success story
every month almost I'll post to my
socials of how I grew month over month
year over year on YouTube and in the
first five years I had seven thousand
subscribers or so
five years in five years in of making
content
seven thousand subscribers a lot of you
are already ahead of that a lot of you
could get there a lot faster than me
you know how do you keep going when
you're not getting traction when in year
one you have a hundred subscribers
I I just had the discipline to keep
making content to keep following through
and 12 000 videos later here we are
and and people can get there faster you
don't have to be as slow as me you know
I took I took a long time and I had a
lot of issues I was shy and secure and
introverted and felt like you had to be
you know type A personality to win and
all of these all of these limiting
beliefs all sorts of issues and you can
get there a lot faster than me but it
still requires a discipline to follow
through and do it and I really think
it's one of the only things that saved
me rule number nine is change your
environment the environment makes such a
huge difference for who you are and your
daily habits and what you believe about
yourself and the environment is not just
the people who are around you although
that definitely helps you know if you've
got negative friends or family around
you you want to eliminate them
completely or spend a lot less time with
them because it's really really really
hard to have a beautiful plant grow when
it's just you know toxic waste being
poured on top of them doable but really
really really difficult and so changing
that can really help and one of the best
ways I found to do it is content
it's content it's why I make so much
content for these channels that
hopefully you wake up today and there's
a piece of content there waiting for you
whether it's me or showcasing somebody
else across all my channels or making
multiple pieces of content every single
day to try to hit it in the right way
maybe today's message with the right
voice is the one that makes a difference
for you and if you can shift
the amount of entertainment you're doing
or just shutting off the world some of
the content that you consume just helps
you shut off the world and Escape versus
educational content that helps you learn
improve get better and solve the problem
right entertainment is let's forget
about the problem and just laugh at
something else
education is let's learn to actually fix
the problem that has happened in our
life right I want to lean in on that a
lot more it doesn't mean that
entertainment doesn't exist in your life
it's not only education but if you can
shift the needle towards education to be
around the people who inspire you even
if you've never met them
it can really move the needle for your
your inner dialogue and your
self-confidence at rule number 10 the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is press forward I am not feeling
so hot this morning don't know if it's
just a lingering effects of the uh
variant or what but I'm just super low
energy a little nauseous a little dizzy
but uh still getting my still getting my
son stuck at my walk still gonna do my
fast and still make as much progress as
we can some days you can do more than
others
just make sure on the days that are less
than others
that you're still getting something done
you don't mail it in if you don't give
up then you don't quit what's the quote
sometimes you can fly sometimes you can
take the car sometimes you can run
sometimes you can crawl
keep moving forward keep moving forward
when life gets hard when you have every
reason in the world
to turn back what do you do you press
forward
who's watching a YouTube video for three
hours the the entire world right like
think about if you're gonna teach if
you're gonna make a video talking about
how do you become an influential leader
where am I going to learn that from
nobody and the people who are sharing it
like go to YouTube and search people are
talking about it are they as good as
Rory Vaden on that topic no it's like
somebody who came from Instagram and you
know they're 25 years old and still
trying to figure it out but they're
gaining a lot of traction and attention
because people like you who actually
know what they're talking about aren't
on the platform so there's giant demand
and consumption and very little very
little Supply period and and almost no
quality Supply so like am I too early am
I too late on YouTube we're just getting
started inside of Education uh so if I
wanted to learn how to become that
influential leader
if you did a four minute video how much
you're gonna teach me in four minutes
not a lot but if you talk for an hour or
you did a coaching session with somebody
or you had a guest coming on sharing
something people would watch that
because it's the best thing there
available and then when you've got your
next launch your book your course your
program your private membership like I
love this Rory guy nobody's talking like
him how do I get more of him and they
want to pay for the access to get into
everything that you're offering and so
you don't worry about giving away too
too much there I mean like uh
I mean how many of those videos is it is
it kind of more like have one really
killer two-hour video
or are you trying to like crank because
to do that every week would be pretty
tough not to mention you know if you did
an hour-long video every week that'd be
that'd be a lot of content
um like what would you be charging for
if you were giving away that much so is
it kind of like have a couple key key
trainings out there and do it that way
or
it depends what game you're playing uh
often the best thing to sell is access
so the best thing to sell is access to a
community uh so if you're trying to sell
your your program your community which
is awesome I was able to you know had
the honor to speak in front of if you
had a lot of long-form content that was
getting millions of views you're gonna
convert a lot of those people to want to
spend more time with you because they
love how you think like you're you're a
weird duck you think differently than
other people like I want to think the
way Rory thinks and I want to be around
him more often so I want to join his
community
um it's less about the actual ideas a
lot a lot of people have paid programs a
lot of the same content is in the
YouTube video as in the paid program
it's just packaged all together so it's
easy to find it's sequential there's
Community there's access and so that's
really what we're selling not just the
information I'm I put out I'm giving you
everything I got nothing to sell here
I'm giving you the best like you're
asking me questions this is what I do is
what I teach people will still some of
the names that you mentioned want me
need to help them with their Channel I'm
telling them the same thing that I'm
telling you guys right now here on Rory
vaden's show right so that I think
builds credibility builds trust and it
makes people want to have a deeper
relationship with you and buy all your
stuff if you're not happy right now it's
probably because you're not growing
humans want to grow we want to learn we
want to improve we want to get better we
want to feel like we're making
meaningful progress somewhere and when
we feel like we're learning and growing
and the work that we do matters we feel
great right if you felt great when you
learn the new skill when you when you
help somebody out when you felt that the
work you were doing was meaningful it
felt amazing
but if you have too many days in a row
where you feel like it's too hard it's
too big you're not growing you're not
learning there's
there's no hope
that leads down I really dangerous and
negative path not where we want to be
and part of why we become entrepreneurs
is because we want to grow right because
we're we don't want to have a crappy
boring job working for somebody else
wasting our talents away I remember my
my I didn't have that many jobs I had a
landscaping job which is super boring
just every day just rolling out of grass
and then I had a data entry job
where this really turned me off of the
corporate world where
I was doing the work of
we had six people five people on my team
and I was doing more work than all of
the others combined
and I didn't take lunch breaks I just I
just kept working and my boss wasn't
happy that because I was overhead
lighting gave me headaches I used to
have to bring in
some snacks like food or popcorn or
carrots or something so I didn't get
crazy headaches and my boss didn't like
that I was eating a snack while I was
working
and I got into trouble and almost got
fired
even though I was doing more work than
my entire team combined and it just
really
turned me off of the corporate world to
realize hey this is
this doesn't make any sense
I wasn't growing
you know I wasn't learning
I wasn't improving
and so you can examine your own life
if you feel like you're in a rut
chances are you haven't learned anything
recently
and so we can we can plan for this you
know you can change your schedule so
that you can focus on learning you can
put it into your daily calendar and
this is where I think it becomes the
greatest benefit my greatest tactic or
strategy for you
for myself
is schedule in learning schedule in
growing
so for me it's my own videos you know I
make these videos
hopefully for you that you learn and
improve and something Sparks for you but
I'm making for me I'm making for me
because I need it because I need to be
around people who are doing big things
and that I know that every day there's a
video for me amen it's it's going to be
positive it's going to be uplifting it's
going to spread believe it's going to be
motivational or inspiring it's going to
be Tactical
and I know that on my channel I'm going
to get content that I want and so I've
hired a whole team and built the whole
business basically around making content
that I want to watch and thankfully
enough of you guys want to watch it as
well that it it I can build a business
and have a team
but if I didn't or nobody else cared
about it I would still do it for me you
know it may not be as fancy I mean I
have as much intros and all that stuff
but I would still have it for me because
I need it and so
we tend to catch these things too late
because it's not part of our habits and
routines
so if you notice you go to an event or
you watch a video and you get all
inspired and you're you got energy and
you're working and things are amazing
cool and then
have weeks or months gone by and you
realize what happened to me what how did
I fall off the horse it's so quickly
where did my energy go has it happened
to you
chances are is because it wasn't
scheduled
you know part of the entrepreneur roller
coaster is because we're bouncing from
one high to the next
without having any scheduled in learning
and growth
and so
my challenge to you would be to try to
figure out how can we schedule in
learning and growing every day
and so it starts with figuring out okay
what medium do you like the most you
know for me I like videos I like being
able to see stuff it just makes it so
much easier for me I'm a visual learner
before YouTube was a thing I learned
from books
that was the best thing available at the
time now I still have a habit of reading
10 pages at least a night but I don't
get most of my learning from books I get
most of my learning from videos but for
you maybe it's videos if you're watching
this maybe it's books maybe it's
podcasts
something like where do you get the best
learning and then the great thing about
where we are right now is there's so
much content there's so many people to
learn from there's so many people
creating
things out there that you can go and
learn from them
you know if I look at an Eric Thomas or
an Oprah Winfrey they have a similar
message just a different delivery style
and so whatever you want to learn
chances are somebody's already making
content on it
and so just go and find them and think
about who you're following right now
like do an audit of who you follow right
now we fall in on YouTube we've fallen
on Instagram or Tick Tock or what
podcasts you listen to or what books are
you picking up
and how many of those people that you're
following are subscribed to actually
make you feel
ambitious and hopeful and better about
yourself and give you strategies and
light you up and feel like you're
learning and growing right that's the
whole point of this we're trying to make
growing and learning a consistent habit
so how many people that you're following
actually make you want to learn and grow
and how many of them are you just
mindlessly scrolling through you know
when you load your Instagram or your
YouTube when you're just scrolling and
scrolling and scrolling and two hours
have gone by and
not only have you not learned anything
you feel worse about your life because
now you haven't been productive
you know you just kind of mindlessly
entertain yourself but it wasn't even
that entertaining you know what just
happened to the past two hours of my
life has that happened to you cool
unfollow those people
it's not that they're bad people
that that content doesn't light you up
and then start to be around the people
who do
and the easiest way is through content
so if it's my channel hey good news we
got content every single day for you
you'll never run out of having chemical
content to watch but it could be
somebody else it's somebody else in
marketing their business or
entrepreneurship or person development
or whatever category you're in
to subscribe to those people and be
around them as much as possible and
watch your videos every day schedule it
in for me I go for a walk every morning
call it my believe walk I just like
getting some sun on my face and fresh
air and getting out of the home and it
just gives me some perspective and a
little bit of motion and helps me set up
my day and then I'll I'll have a video
going
from my channel
and I'm every morning will be somebody
else it'll be
Elon Musk or Oprah Winfrey or Mel
Robbins or Tony Robbins or garyvee or
Tom Billy or whatever and that's what we
do is pull the best clips that I would
learn from and then we share it with
everybody else but that's a part of my
daily routines and I've I've seen my own
growth and development and learning and
bravery and courage and momentum and
consistency
be directly contributed and correlated
to
the content that I'm consuming daily
and so step one is to unfollow and
unsubscribe from the people who just
make you waste time feel worse about
yourself get Envy
or just mindlessly tune out
and step two then is to figure out
I need to make learning you need to make
learning growing a part of your daily
habit and so where in your calendar can
that fit
if it's over breakfast if it's a morning
walk if it's a afternoon lunch like
where in your calendar can you put
learning from your preferred Style video
podcast books Etc learning into your
daily calendar if you did that your life
will change if you did that every day
for the next year every day if you did
that if you scheduled that in and you
actually did it and you you watch the
video write a book or listen to podcasts
that inspired you said you know what I
can do this I can do more I can be more
I can accomplish This I Gotta stop
thinking small and stop doubting myself
and stop telling myself that I suck and
I can't do it I can't do this like if
you felt that energy every day from
watching a piece of content that you
intentionally put into your habits
routine every day for the next year
your life will totally transform
you will be a totally different person
which then allows you to serve more to
help more to make more money to guide
more to be a leader more all of it all
of your Ambitions and dreams everything
that you want
is all possible
but you have to factor learning and
growing into your daily consistent
habits and routine your energy changes
how you show up
when you are happy positive optimistic
full of life Creative Energy you you
make amazing things
but when you feel negative down
depressed side for yourself low energy
you know you don't make amazing things
and this is not
something new that I'm telling you you
know this
the challenges we are not in a high
energy state
consistently enough just to stay
consistent on our goals so follow
through to create the momentum because
we allow outside forces as well as our
internal voice to keep us small to keep
us protected to keep us scared to the
Press our courage muscle
and then even though you have great
ideas and great Ambitions and a great
heart and desire to serve it doesn't
happen it doesn't happen because
the energy isn't connected to it if
you've got
a big idea
but low energy
nothing happens
you don't follow through and you end up
seeing other people with a worse version
of your idea
but just more energy and go off and do
it have you ever seen it happen you ever
seen somebody
make tons of money have a huge impact
off of your idea somebody with less
heart and less vision and less
creativity but they just they just did
it they just got started they just took
action it just stayed consistent in
their energy and they made it happen and
you didn't because you allowed the
energy to dip
and so
If energy is so important then how do we
how do we manage your energy how do we
keep it high and doesn't mean that you
always have to be on top of the world
and you don't have to delude yourself
and say I'm amazing this is going to be
the greatest day of all time like you
don't
doing things that you don't believe
won't help you get the energy that you
need because you'll do those things say
This is BS this isn't working
you don't always have to be in Peak
energy
but what you didn't need to do is being
the right energy to serve your mission
and whatever you're doing today so let
me use me as an example on today
it's a great example because I did not
sleep well last night had had two and a
half hours sleep just tossing and
turning and
just could not could not get to sleep so
I slept from like 6 30 to 9 o'clock did
not sleep until 6 30 in the morning and
that is thankfully a rare occurrence you
know most nights I get eight hours sleep
seven and a half to eight and a half
hours sleep
but
on a day like today when I woke up and
did not have a ton of energy I did not
wake up and say yes I feel like crushing
it let's go and
I didn't want to do something that would
feel fake and disingenuous because if
you don't believe it then it's not going
to happen anyway so what did I do well
first off videos have to happen today
because that's part of my identity right
so momentum has to happen
so if you start to train yourself and
you create a calendar and say okay
today is a blank I'm filming this on a
Tuesday today's a Tuesday Tuesday's my
video day no matter what I'm filming
videos I gotta film videos it's got to
happen it may not be my best video
but I'm going to show up and give it my
the best that I've got the best energy
this is this is a lot lower energy than
I would normally show up with a video
but it's a different vibe it's a
different kind of energy and hopefully
it still serves and maybe maybe you like
and connect more with this energy then
I've been yelling in the car I don't
know but videos have to happen first off
second get outside
you know get outside get fresh air get
some sun on my face if you you know you
want to change your energy you want to
shift where you're at and how you're
thinking because it's part physical
energy but also just mental energy how
do you feel about what you're doing and
what's going to happen today and getting
out of your home changing your physical
environment and getting some sun on your
face
can make a huge difference so every
morning I have my believe walk and I'm
walking around the park getting some
green getting some sun hopefully it's
not raining today's a beautiful day and
everybody it starts to make you feel a
little bit happier a little bit more in
the right energy space
music is a great way to change your
energy and often what we do is we put on
songs that make us feel how we currently
are so if you feel sad you put on a sad
song If you feel low you put on a low
song and you feel chill you put on a
Chill song
where what we want to do is if you want
to change your energy put on the song
that matches that energy
if you want to feel happier upbeat put
unhappy or beat songs I have a playlist
on my channel called hashtag believe all
caps on the on the letters believe
that's all the songs that I listen to
and every day I've got that playlist
going I pick a random song and it just
starts playing and they're all songs
that if they came on it would make me
move
and when you move you start to change
your energy
what I'm trying to do is again not
create some fake energy but something I
can actually connect with I'm putting on
songs that I actually like I actually
like having some sunshine on my face you
know I actually like doing the work that
I'm about to do
what it requires you showing up with a
certain level of energy
and then the last one is
you know who you're feeding your mind
with who are you around who you're
surrounded by both the people in your
life you know actual humans
and the videos that you watch or books
that you read and podcasts you consume I
remember on the weekend
you gotta guard against this it's crazy
so on the weekend I went to go
meet an old family friend
and
he just had
a lot of limiting
beliefs about him and what he's creating
and where he wants to go and it wasn't
it wasn't meant to be a coaching session
I'm not there to help him but just a
really negative low energy on a weekend
and I'm you know that's not usually part
of my routine on the weekend and so I go
to meet him
and my whole day ended up being thrown
off until I caught it at night to say
why why am I so low and negative today
in comparison to what I would normally
be and I thought back that oh yeah you
know what ever since I went to see him I
was fine in the morning I went to see
him and had this negative ripple effect
you know like you could have a positive
ripple effect on people you watch a
video and it can have a positive ripple
effect on you but but there's negative
equal effects too
and the people who you're surrounded by
who you're hanging out with or you're
watching on YouTube or podcasts Etc they
can have a negative ripple effect on you
as well
and so he had this
negative ripple effect on me that lasted
almost the whole day until I caught it
in the evening said this isn't what I
want
it's not even my voice it's like his
voice planted in me why am I feeling
this way thinking this way I don't like
it
and so it became a conscious choice and
I've applied a lot of the same things I
got it I went outside went outside reset
get some fresh hair it always helps me
put on some music songs that I actually
like not some fake song that somebody
else likes and says dance to this it'll
make you feel good as long as I actually
like there are some songs that if it
came on
it would
make you move it doesn't mean you get up
and dance and go and crazy but
there's some songs that if it came on
you you would Bob your head or you would
tap your feet or bounce your knee
there's some songs that just make you do
that right so put on one of those songs
it would naturally make you feel happier
so I did that too and then in terms of
just guarding against people I made a
note that hey the next time I go see
this person he's a he's a family friend
so the next time I go see him
which is not often but still the next
time I see him I need to remind myself
of this
you know that that I need to I need to
have my shield ready
I need to give love as much as possible
and I'm not gonna allow his negativity
to to break my shield you know the
permeate through
and so the more that you can catch those
things
the more you'll stay in a more energetic
state
and all of this again is not trying to
force fake energy and have you feel like
you're doing something unnatural I think
it's actually the most natural thing of
all time I think getting sun is natural
I think smiling and being optimistic is
natural I think everything I think the
negativity inside your head was planted
there was put there by other people
that's what's unnatural when you were a
kid and smiling and happy had dreams to
the Future everything was possible
everything was hopeful
sure we had bad days but you were a
happy kid
and all of those dreams and positivity
get squashed out of us by other people
who hate their lives and so I think
having energy is actually the most
natural thing not every day has to be on
top of the world but having positive
energy is natural having sunshine and
leading to happiness is natural putting
on music and and dancing and moving is
natural
being around other positive optimistic
happy people when you're around them
you'll naturally be more positive
optimistic and happy and so it's about
finding what is a natural flow for you
that when you do these things
it brings out a better energy in you
it brings out a happier more positive
more optimistic you and if you know what
some of those things are
you can copy my list if you want some of
them right sunshine music videos
then put into your daily routine
put into your daily calendar every day
this has to happen
because if you did the thing just
imagine this you've had days when you
felt energetic and you've had days when
you didn't and every would everybody
would give you the the out right like a
day like today two and a half hours
sleep
everybody would give me the I was like
it's okay you don't have to do it
there are days when you need to bring
the energy
if you did that every day
just imagine for the next month every
day
you did the thing that puts you in a
better energy state
and that you're on top of the world and
then a fake high every day but a better
energy state
you did the thing in the morning that
put you in a better energy State for the
next 30 days how much does your life
change
how much is how you show up change how
much is the work that you do change how
much does your bank account change how
much is the impact you're creating
change how much of a better father or
mother or husband or wife are you
because you're showing up with more
energy more positive energy I remember I
was at a a video event
and there were these two brothers who
were speaking together okay who are
friends of mine and one of them was
seasoned and had like done tons of
events and presentations and the other
guy was his very first time ever doing a
presentation and they're on the main
stage they got a thousand people Plus in
the room and he's like freaking out his
brother and brother may not have been
making it better he's like oh yeah this
is easy and it's like it wasn't easy for
you I'm I'm struggling and I told them
to just go out and actually say that
you're nervous
like just get on stage yeah say I'm
nervous like this is my first time ever
speaking and I'm really nervous to be
here
because it makes you a lot more
relatable yes yeah and so so he said
that and some people clapped them up you
know for even admitting that and then at
the end he got so much love from
people's like that was your that was
amazing I can't believe that was your
first time ever doing it and by him
admitting it it relieved the pressure of
having to be perfect
right it's actually more of an
inspiration that you're willing to get
up there and risk failing yes then if it
was super easy for you to go off and do
the reason why I did my tour because I
was really afraid to do yes speaking yes
I said okay I'm gonna I'm gonna do the
thing I'm most terrified about and I'm
gonna go speak every four days
I'm gonna host my own workshop and speak
every four days and who knows if people
are going to show up and Rule Number 10
the last time before some very special
bonus Clips is take immediate action the
first question that came in on the poll
was how can we focus on one thing with
too much information
so at the beginning of anything it
always can feel overwhelming right if
you're thinking about I want to start on
YouTube I want to start on social media
I want to start writing my book I want
to start like whatever new project you
want to start it always feels
overwhelming it always feels like it's
too big it always feels like you don't
have enough information you can't wrap
your head around what's going on and so
what I like to do is just trying to
figure out where are the boundaries like
what is it that I actually need to learn
and at the beginning I get super
frustrated of any project
just trying to figure out where are the
gates because I'm I love optimizing I
love efficiency I love making things as
tight as possible but at the beginning
creativity is messy and you can't
prematurely optimize something we try to
optimize too soon when you don't know
the boundaries you end up not being able
to make any progress so at the beginning
of any project I will take some time sit
in my frustration and just basically try
to figure out where the gates are around
it so what's the most recent one I think
um figuring out AdWords and advertising
has been one of those things for me in
figuring out okay what ads do I run how
do I put them up what are the placements
what what's the conversions uh the
demographics you know all of the things
that seem overwhelming at the beginning
and it's frustrating to know which ads
to serve to which audiences and just
testing testing testing testing until I
kind of get a sense of okay this is
where the gates are and then
make it efficient and squish it down and
optimize it
um so at the beginning for me it's just
research right research plane testing
find don't get so overwhelmed by the the
big picture that you don't take any
action right like what's the smallest
possible thing you can just do to start
gaining momentum and then
that first step seems impossible but
when you go back it's like oh I did that
I did that first step that's pretty cool
anyway so I hope that makes sense right
it's taking that big idea that seems
overwhelming that seems impossible and
then finding one step that you can do
today because as long as you have it as
some big dream in your head that is
impossible then you never take any
action and then you know it's a year
later and you still haven't done the
thing yet because it still seems too
impossible and I see it all the time
with entrepreneurs who are getting
started people ask me how to get started
on YouTube how do I get started as an
author how do I get started as a speaker
and and you think you've got to have
this perfect plan and the perfect year
and all of this perfect stuff and then
it's a year later and you still haven't
done the thing immediate action momentum
whatever you think the problem is with
cancer or or whatever like well I think
you know I think the woman who solves
cancer would have solved it by now but
she's a she's a manager at an accounting
firm hating her life because she never
either didn't didn't go to medical
school or never even thought about it or
uh just never chase it down like I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level genius at something you're the
greatest in the world at something and
we either don't believe in that or we
don't chase it down and we end up living
a life that is less than what it could
be and so even me I mean my biggest
problem is a lack of belief to get to
the next step and so that's what I wake
up every day trying to solve um you know
never gonna do it and I wake up every
day trying to do it your challenges
don't only make you stronger they allow
you to serve better
I think the default
answer for a lot of people is that your
challenges make you stronger your
challenges will you know to grow muscle
you have to break you have to break your
muscle first and all of these obstacles
that they put in your way allow you to
have a a better life they're making you
stronger they're making you more
powerful and that's all true yes and the
thing that helps me the most is just
tying it back to service because I think
you know humans are built to serve you
are built to serve when you can connect
the challenge that you're going through
as something that's then going to
inspire and help other people
at least for me it always gives me a lot
more strength and a lot more courage to
do the thing that I need to do as
opposed to just being about me getting
stronger I find a lot of times me
getting stronger is not enough it's not
enough of a reason compared to it's
going to help somebody else as well so
you know that's you hope this video
helps you as well so I think about
when I was doing my tour 2019 and I
broke my neck it was one of the most
challenging times in my life in that
it's already hard enough I'm already you
know on the road report of the year on
the road 90 straight days me Nina my
camera mandani and there were a lot of
challenges in making that whole tour
happen and new city every four days and
all of the stuff that goes into you know
it was my first ever tour and then I
broke my neck two-thirds of the way
through so as if things weren't hard
enough now I break my neck I can't drive
anymore uh I'm in insane amounts of pain
I have a concussion uh and I'm I'm still
making videos I I struggled with the
decision this is a real decision do I do
I quit the tour or not so I quit the
tour do I go home
there's still another month on the road
it's not just me it's also Nina who has
to do a lot more work now she's got to
drive this giant Suburban across the
country uh Danny the camera guy has to
do a lot more work you know it's a lot
of stress I'm basically out of
commission and all I could do was talk
which is great for speaking but it sucks
for everything else so what do we do
the thing that made me want to at least
try to keep going I didn't know that I
would go for another month but I thought
let's just do the next city let's just
do the next city let's go to Kansas City
Kansas City was the next stop let's go
to Kansas City and see what happens
what got me through it was
thinking about somebody in the audience
thinking about one of you guys who is
struggling with something physically up
until that point I dealt with a lot of
mental issues mental issues mindset
issues things like believing you're not
good enough lack of self-worth you don't
have a message to share imposter
syndrome all of those things right even
here we're filming we're about to go
through a car wash uh we're we're next
so we're probably gonna get some crazy
noise I have to talk loud I used to
be so worried about that stuff that I
wouldn't I wouldn't feel like oh I can't
film going to a car wash you know the
noise whatever now I look at it as
opportunities like let's go like that's
not a good enough reason maybe the video
quality sucks I you know I hope not
maybe you can't hear me loud enough I
hope not but but not letting those
things get in your way because that
stuff happens all the time was it hard
for you to dig inside and say I'm gonna
work on Evan I love taking on new things
like you have a different modality that
you wanna no nobody's models ever quite
fit me so it's cool but I'm happy to try
on the next model you guys do you have
your eight step personality test cool
I'm a electrifier awesome
all of them are good
good pass like I'm not locked into one
modality like it's got to be the Colby
score it's got to be the Myers-Briggs
there's got to be the whatever but they
all teach you a little bit about
yourself even even down to
I just had my DNA tested and from the
DNA test they show you hey based on your
genes you're more susceptible to these
kinds of foods and this kind of activity
and all this kind of stuff like okay
those are like their averages so it's
it's a good starting point
I love trying stuff I love trying stuff
for me to learn and also to to
demonstrate to other people that go try
stuff be the change you want to see in
the world
one of my favorite quotes Mahatma Gandhi
if you're not happy with something
you're not happy with a situation you
fix it that's why entrepreneurs are
going to solve all the problems
not as much as there's government and
big business I think it's entrepreneurs
it's us we're going to solve all the
world's problems because we see a
problem and we want to fix it we want to
solve it that's what we do that's the
most exciting part of being an
entrepreneur is that you're not waking
up and driving to some job that you hate
where the work you're doing does not
matter has no meaning and instead you
get to do something that is actually
going to touch somebody's life and that
is Meaningful to you right you get the
pick you get to decide you get to choose
and we're trying to make the world a
better place we're gonna make money
doing it too but Mission first purpose
first and then making money along the
way in service of others and it's in
that combination of what you love doing
with what brings value to other people
that you have a successful business
part of that then becomes being a leader
as well and I think a lot of
entrepreneurs struggle with being the
leader because at the beginning
we are just managing ourselves and
that's hard enough right it's like have
you had a hard time managing yourself
have you had a hard time sticking to
your routines and keeping to your
motivation and staying strong and the
things that you say you're going to do
like self-management self-leadership is
hard enough now we're going to go off
and lead other people as well and where
do we learn about leadership we don't go
to school for this we don't have
programs we don't probably have great
mentors to help us if you had jobs in
the past or maybe you're at a job right
now you probably don't have the greatest
leaders around you most people suck at
it
but it doesn't have to be
extremely difficult
and it took me a long time to get used
to it and get better at it and I'm still
learning and improving we've got almost
40 people on the team now and
can people ask me what's my definition
my definition of leadership it's I want
people to win more than I want them to
win with me
and so the key becomes
wanting the humans that are on your team
to win as humans
more than you want them to win with you
that you can have this little
disconnection obviously they have to do
the work if they're going to work with
you but sometimes the best thing for
them to do is to move on
not because they're not doing their job
but because it's the best thing for them
and so when I connect with the people on
my team it's always trying to figure out
where do they want to go what do they
want to learn what do they what do they
want to improve on and I see everybody
as running parallel paths with me so the
people around you the people even us
right now what we're doing right now
this is a parallel path you've decided
to watch this video I decided to record
this video and we're sharing this moment
in time and maybe you never watch
another Urban Carmichael video again
maybe you end up watching all my videos
and we end up being Partners on some
future business who knows you know we
haven't seen you every day in the future
but as of right now we're on this
parallel path together and
when somebody's with you walking down
that parallel path
the goal of a great leader I think
should be to try to make that person
leave better than how they came in
right have you ever heard the expression
um my grandfather used to tell me about
you know when you go to a hotel
or you go to a new city or you go to a
new event they always try to leave the
place better than when you came
you know and hopefully that's our goal
for life you know in this life we try to
leave
the world a little better than how it
was when we came in
and so if you take that approach to
leadership that when you're with the
people on your team
and maybe it's for a week on some really
short internship maybe it's for a year
maybe it's for five years ten years
maybe it's their entire life with you
that they have left a little bit better
than when they came in because they got
to hang around you and not taking it as
an ego play like I'm gonna make this
person's life better because I am so
amazing it's more out of care
genuine care
for the people on your team and I think
when we're first hiring
we suck at it
most entrepreneurs suck at hiring most
entrepreneurs their first employee is
not with them you know a year two years
three years later because they hired the
wrong person they have no idea how to
manage that person it's not that that
person sucks it's more that you know you
don't have the skill set we don't have
the skill sets at the beginning to know
how to even find the right person let
alone manage them and so
you know we that's the skill that we
have to develop but I think it just
starts with genuinely caring about the
people on your team that yes they have
to get the work done right there's a job
that has to get done but how we often
think about it is more from a selfish
perspective as I need to get this stuff
off my plate right you're overloaded
with work right who's over are you
overloaded with work for overloaded with
work
so I gotta hire somebody to take this
off my plate so I don't have to deal
with that ever again and it frees up my
time to go and do other stuff
right so familiar listen at the
beginning when you bring on team it
takes more time
it takes more time than it frees up
because you have to train them you have
to listen to them you have to care for
them you have to answer their questions
if you treat them like a robot or a
monkey
they're not going to stick with you
you're going to constantly be hiring and
firing and hiring firing are you going
to be massively frustrated and
overwhelmed and a lot of a lot of
entrepreneurs get stuck in that cycle
where has this happened to you you hire
somebody you know looks great on paper
you're so excited for it to go and then
it doesn't work out a couple months
later and then you decide that you know
what I'm just gonna do it all myself
right I know I can get it done I'm just
gonna do it on myself does that happen
to you
that is not the path to building a
movement you know you can have a great
little solo business for yourself but
that's not how you change the world
that's not how you realize your
potential it's not how you have the
impact that you know you're capable of
having you know you have to have people
around you if you've got a big mission
if you have a big mission that's just
it's just you cool go for it but if
you've got a big mission then it needs
to be team and that becomes a skill set
that you have to pick up and learn
and so leadership for me is again caring
about people as humans more than caring
about them winning with you it's about
discovering what they want to learn and
grow and improve at and you being a
vehicle to help them do that and it's
surprising how often you can find things
that support them and support you not
all the time I remember having one guy
in my team who his dream was to be a
baker
like what
I don't have an interest in opening up a
bake shop right but ultimately you
should you should leave us and go do
your passion because because I can't
help you inside of this job
until I open a bake shop that can really
support you in what you want to do and
so even though he wanted to stay he was
staying more out of fear and insecurity
than actually doing something he was
deeply passionate about
so I gave him till the end of the year
if it was you know summer it's given to
the end of the year to okay you're as of
the end of the year you you're out and
you have to go find a job I love you but
you have to go find something that is
in line with your dream because you
staying here is is safe and it's
actually squashing your dreams
you have to go do your thing and so you
know he had to go and move on it was
appreciative for it and giving him time
not like okay you're fired next week
and then you have other people though
and usually you can find something
inside of what they care about so the
the amount of people who I've met on my
team who then they want to learn graphic
design or they want to learn Photoshop
or they want to learn
copywriting or they want to learn how to
come up with good titles or they want to
learn
better communication skills if they want
to learn they have their list of like
the things that they want to learn
it's like cool as long as there's
something that we've got
that can help you with that some kind of
program some project something that can
also bring value to the company then
let's do it because when people are
working on the things that they feel
like they're growing in and they're
learning in
they're gonna
it's just a good thing to do because
it's it's from the heart you know and
when they feel connected to your heart
everybody's happier and more productive
but it's also just good business
strategy if you want to just put your
Exo business strategy hat on it's it's
great this is how Karma becomes
practical if somebody's engaged and they
feel like they're learning and they're
growing and they're improving you're
going to get the best of them versus you
have to feel bored and stuck and
learning nothing new right that's what
most people do in their jobs and
honestly the bar for leadership is so
low
it's so low most people wake up and
drive to that job that they hate so all
you have to do to be honest to be their
best boss is probably just to not be a
bad boss you don't have to be a great
boss you just have to not not be a bad
boss you need to treat somebody
like a normal human being and actually
have a little bit of care and compassion
and curiosity to see them win in life
you do that you're already probably
their best boss of all time I think
that's a pretty low standard but it's a
great starting point
to then be able to say hey no I want I
want this person to have come out of my
organization whether that's in a month
or year 10 years from now a better human
because they were with us and it's
totally possible
it's just a mindset shift
that
these people are on your team
because they have something to prove as
well and they want to learn and it's not
just about you saving your time and
dumping stuff off of your plate and
giving it to somebody else so it can be
all delegated away
it's that you are a leader
and you care about people and you want
to see them win
and you're responsible for making sure
that they get pushed outside their
comfort zone
you got a big mission inside you
huge mission
and you can't do this alone
and you may not have the skills yet
to be the leader that you want to be
maybe not yet
but you've got a big heart and honestly
that's the biggest skill that you ever
need the biggest difference between you
and the people who you look up to are
that they started
and you're still thinking about it it's
one of the most frustrating things
in helping entrepreneurs
that I deal with on a day-to-day basis
is that seeing so much potential in
people seen so much heart and love and
care is like you you could be serving so
much and helping so much and having such
a big impact
and and we're stuck
we're stuck
and this was me too I was stuck it took
me forever to get started and I thought
I had to have the the perfect cameraman
my first video if you go back and watch
it on my channel I had my friend come
and film it and record it for me because
I was worried about it not being perfect
enough that I didn't know the gear and
didn't know the microphone and the
lighting and the setup and I I memorized
the script because I didn't want to say
the wrong words I had to be perfect uh
most of my early videos were still
mostly voice over because I could write
a script and have it perfect and just
have b-roll and it wouldn't be me on
camera afraid of making mistake and
saying the wrong things and messing up
and that's one of the main reasons why
it took me so long to grow you know if
you look at my journey of
making what for five years seven
thousand subscribers something like that
it was I was stuck I was I was
I was too afraid to do the next thing I
was too afraid to get in the race I was
making content at least I was one decent
thing for whatever reason I stay
consistent on on doing stuff but I was
afraid to take the next step the big
step to go off and do it and
a lot of you are already way better than
than I was when I started
and when I'm on interviews and I'm I'm
doing events and presentations and I see
the audience and I see who's there and I
see the skill and the and the heart just
the this is the thing that kills me the
most it's like the hearts like you want
you've got such a good heart you want to
do so much
and then there's just no action there's
no momentum because of the fear
if you could make one change
this year that would really move the
needle it would be to stop judging
yourself for the content that you're
making or the product you're putting out
or the service and just expect it to
suck and keep going how does a person
for lack of better terms a broken person
get over that to be able to help other
people that might be
when they themselves haven't healed yet
for me
[Music]
serving is part of the healing process
so
for me to heal and get better
I need to be helping others right so you
saw me on that tour
Pittsburgh was if it wasn't our first
time it was one of our first jobs was
number one first stop and then you went
to Cleveland the last stop and you saw
the difference between me Cleveland I
had my I had a broken neck I don't know
if you stuck away to the end like that I
was on the floor for 45 minutes just at
the end because like I was I was gone I
gave everything
but we had a real decision when I when I
had broken my neck like do I keep going
or go home and everybody was saying go
home like it's crazy you go home
everybody would understand if you go
home because you broke your neck you
could concussion all this but for me
I would get more healing by being with
people and helping them than me being on
the couch at home
just healing or feeling sorry for myself
or whatever and I had all sorts of
you know I was I was gaining lots of
weight because I wasn't moving around I
had like this giant scab on my forehead
I wasn't thinking as clearly as I
normally would be the events were worse
right I wasn't I didn't have the same
energy you saw me at the end in
Cleveland but I still didn't have as
much energy there as I did in Pittsburgh
when I first started because I I wasn't
moving around sitting there for four
hours with ice packs on me but that
became part of my healing process so for
me I actually healed more by being with
people and sitting with them and helping
them then by me being by myself I
haven't gone through any serious
depression or I haven't wanted to commit
suicide and some of the things that you
know you've talked about but one of my
favorite Expressions that I forget who
said it was like don't suffer alone you
know like when you're when you're alone
just and you when you're suffering sorry
just don't be alone reach out to
somebody have have a community have a
group have a friend so you're not by
yourself because you're you can do
stupid things when you're by yourself
when you're really in really dark places
and you've you pulled yourself off the
edge you know in there which is amazing
amazing but a lot of people don't you're
never fully healed I don't think but you
gain more healing as you continue to
help people at least that's what I tell
myself and what I find works for me out
is real but I think most burnout happens
because people are not doing the thing
that they actually love doing it's not
just about being busy and keeping your
mind occupied all day you can be busy
and hate your life and get burnt out if
I was an accountant I would hate my life
and burn out in a day because I don't
like being an accountant but doing this
thing that I love I put in way more
effort way more work and I love it it's
been 10 plus years of still having my
YouTube channel and I'm not burnt out if
anything I'm pushing harder than ever
before because I love it and so I think
it's not just about being busy it's
about being busy on the thing that is
your mission for life now compassion
fatigue is a thing doing it so much that
you burn out yourself is possible but
again that is not why most people are
burning out most people I believe are
burning out because they're spending too
much time too much energy too much
effort doing things that they hate and
if you wake up and hate your life and
hate the job you're about to go to then
there's no one wonder why you feel like
you're burning out so I recently came
back from going to Tony Robbins event in
Dallas he invited me to sit in the front
row and uh super blessed and grateful to
have Tony support and I went there with
Alex friend of the channel who helps me
run trying to dance salsa and we're on a
super crunch timeline because Alex was
teaching classes the the evening before
we left and then the day of the last
event and we we rushed down there Alex
was flying in just to get to the event
he's late on the first day we're rushing
to leave on the last day and it's
non-stop if you if you've been to a Tony
Robbins event it's it's all day all
night it's eight in the morning to
midnight and then up again the next day
and doing the same thing and and it's
wild and it's fun it's amazing and my
favorite thing to do whenever I travel
is actually meet believe Nation meet you
guys and so all through the event I wear
my believe hoodie and I'm not wearing
Grand stuff I'm wearing Evan Carmichael
stuff with the plane and the believe on
the back and people are stopping me and
that's actually the best it doesn't take
away from my experience Tony's often on
stage at the top at the beginning every
event saying hey I have some friends of
mine you might know them don't be
celebrities leave them alone don't talk
to them let them have their own
experience and it always makes me sad
when he says that because for me meeting
you guys meeting people who recognize me
and that's a group that I over index
because people who watch Tony videos you
know they're probably going to find my
content
I like it I like it more when people
come and say hi it adds to the
experience for me and then on the last
day before we rushed out to go to the
airport I set up a meet-up right I had
an hour open before having to get to the
airport so let's do a meet up let's do a
local Dallas Richardson Texas Meetup
right and and it could have spent the
time doing something else or sleeping in
or writing my book or doing anything
else but
it's not burnout from you like that
fuels me that gives me more energy I
love it hanging out with believe Nation
gives me more energy than it takes away
and I then took an Uber to get to my to
the airport and the guy who drove the
Uber was actually in the the Meetup in
Richardson's like I gotta leave early
because I got to start my job okay great
and then I book an Uber and there he is
a total fluke but amazing and so it's a
lot of work you know I was all day all
night not connecting with my team not
doing the things that I'm supposed to be
doing and I still make time to be with
people and and make a one-hour Meetup
because that hour was open and
it fuels me but if it was something that
I hated just that half an hour just 15
minutes I'd start to feel like I'm
burning out like I don't want to be here
like this is terrible and so I think
it's really important that you're doing
work that you love that would be a
burnout for other people but not a
burnout for you because you love it so
much so how do you find it how do you
find the work that you love I got a
three-step process called who I how I'm
going to talk about it in depth in my
next book but let's do a super quick
analysis here to help you guys who might
be struggling step number one is who so
you're who is your most important core
value what is your most important core
value as a human being
mine is believe it's the one word most
important value for me so when you
figure out what it is that you stand for
as a human you can then look at your
life and see where you're falling short
if you are unhappy with life it's
because you are living incongruently
with your most important core value so
someone whose core value is freedom as
an example
you can look at your life like are you
allowed to be free are you free at work
are you free in your relationships are
you free you know in these different
areas if not then you're not going to be
happy that's why you're not happy
because your boss doesn't allow you to
have freedom mine is believe so believe
has to be in everything that I touch if
there's a situation that's lacking
believe I'm not going to be happy with
it so that just gives you already an
indication of who you are and starts to
make sense of your life going backwards
and allows you to plan it better going
forward so it's one of the most
important exercises I think anybody can
do figure out what your who is who I how
step two is why so why is your purpose
your purpose comes in your pain your
purpose comes from the deepest darkest
most painful moment in your life
whatever that was your purpose is to
help other people who are currently
going through that thing whatever you
struggled with suffered with endured
felt like you never want to wish that on
your worst enemy never want to go back
and experience again that pain that's
what I'm talking about you want to help
other people who are currently going
through that pain because there's a lot
of people who are currently going
through that thing who you were X number
of years ago there's a lot of people who
are currently like that right now that's
who you want to help for Life that'll
never get old that's your purpose for
life I want to help entrepreneurs for
life I believe in entrepreneurs for life
because I struggled so much as an
entrepreneur and I want to make the path
a little bit easier for everybody else
so that's your wire and your who and
your why are constant they never change
your core values and your purpose are
for life and that's amazing the last
step is how who I how how is your
passion how is how you got out of the
pain that you're in so you struggled
with something how did you get out of it
you may not be fully out of it maybe
you're still on your journey out of it
but you're further ahead than you used
to be how did you get out of it did you
read books did you watch videos did you
meditate did you walk your dogs did you
listen to music like how did you get out
of it how did you get out of it and that
is a recipe that you can teach other
people how you got out of it was not
some random one-off situation you can
teach other people so I struggled a lot
with my business I felt worthless as a
human I wanted to quit I told my partner
that I quit how I got out of it was
model and success I looked at Bill Gates
how he started Microsoft and I applied
those strategies to my business and we
started to see some success 20 years
later what am I doing still modeling
success right I want to learn from Grant
I want to learn from Steve I want to
learn from Kanye I want to learn from
these people it's why keep creating this
content
how I got out of it was studying success
and now I teach other people how to
study success
right how you actually go about doing it
may change when I first started doing it
20 years ago is through books right now
it's through videos and in 10 years 20
years is going to be through VR and a
bunch of other technologies that I'm
sure are coming but
the how you got out is a teachable
recipe that you can give to other people
so if you're struggling with burnout
and you think it's because you don't
love the work that you're doing and you
know that you're destined for something
greater that you do have Michael Jordan
level Talent at something but you don't
know what it is and you want to figure
it out figure it out this is this is the
process this is the easiest process I
know of to get there figure out your who
your one where most important core value
figure out your why your purpose comes
to your pain and figure out your how
which is your passion how you got out of
it you can teach other people and that
will set you up for an amazing life with
hopefully very little burnout and
definitely a lot of purpose success is a
is a is a habit success is how you
showed up today so for me success is
that I put my best effort in
right so as an example today all day I'm
just doing interviews right I had like
four before you and another six after
you and my goal today is to create an
interview that I'm going to be proud to
show my grandkids
right I want my grandkids hey hey
grandkids listening like I want I want
this interview to be the one that I I
gave my best to and that my grandkids
are going to listen to that is Success
at the end of the day it's me saying I'm
proud of myself for what I did not
hitting some goal so learning to tie
yourself like what is success hitting
two million subscribers you know hitting
I didn't even want to celebrate I didn't
even care because the success for me
Isn't hitting the million subscribers
success for me is is showing up today
and having an impact
and so that's what I'm that's what I
celebrate and Pat myself on the back for
every day more than did I get a certain
result what a lot of times people do is
they have this idea and you love the
idea it's like this is this is my big
idea this is going to be my masterpiece
and it's just going to change the world
and it's so exciting and it's so easy to
live in that future world of how
exciting everything's going to be
but the more you live there the bigger
the idea gets and then you realize oh I
need a team and I need to have all these
people and then to make that happen I
need to raise a million dollars and you
just make it bigger and bigger and
bigger and bigger that it becomes
impossible to ever actually do and then
you get depressed like I can never go
out and do that like who am I to go out
and do that
where what I encourage people to do is
have a big goal have a big dream you
need to but then act small you're
thinking big and you're acting small so
whatever it is that you want to do find
one small way to just get started so to
start a YouTube channel you don't need
to have an editor and a researcher and a
production team and be great at all of
this stuff like just do a video and
expect it to suck and be okay with it
sucking and then just suck a little bit
less the next day like
people will make a video and then or
they'll make their first product or
whatever it is and it will suck and then
you know they know it looks good they
know that if they watch a big YouTuber
or they see somebody else's product they
know like well that's what looks good
and I can't make that and so I suck and
then I'm gonna try again it's taking the
big vision and and living there and
loving it but finding the smallest
possible action to get started today
know that it's gonna suck and just keep
the continuous momentum going every
single day I would equate a lot of my
fulfillment comes from the growth that
I'm getting a lot of my fulfillment
comes from like talking to you and and
making this show and and talking about
Cleveland and sharing stories and trying
to help other entrepreneurs like that's
deeply fulfilling for me that's this
isn't work for me this is like the the
second I look at my calendar it's like
oh man really I gotta talk to Jad come
on like if that's my mindset I'm out I'm
not doing those things anymore
um this is deeply fulfilling for me
balance I think is a very personal
question and will adjust throughout time
for every human so what your version of
balance looks like is going to be
different than mine than the rock than
somebody else when you hear the rock
talk about his calendar you know he
needs to work out for five hours a day
or something crazy uh and so when he's
on set he has to wake up five hours
early
to go work out and then then he'll go
and do his movie
and I think that's crazy that's not
balance for me but if you hear him
talking about being in the gym it's his
it's his Zen Zone it's his like he needs
it that's part of balance for him right
so I'd rather be sleeping I'd be
sleeping in my trailer I would not be
working out five hours you know a day
but but I don't look like the rock you
know when you get the results
um so you have to figure what bounce
looks like for you
I think there are
definitely moments where you can lean in
on on gratitude and what you've got but
also want more and strive to go and get
more I think for the most part though
people need to be harder on themselves
like I'd say 95 of the time you need to
be harder in yourself and five percent
of the time you have to be more gentle
on yourself
like when you feel like you can't go
anymore when you've actually like I've
I've did my tour with a broken neck like
the second half or the second the last
third of my tours with a broken neck and
it wasn't when I showed up to Cleveland
I wasn't as good a presenter as I was
before I broke my neck right I had to
just sit at the front of the room and I
couldn't move for four hours while I'm
trying to help people who are in the
room
but I'm really proud of the effort
that I put in right and so all that
really matters is are you proud of you
if I had if I had to skip Cleveland like
if I was in so much pain and I just
skipped Cleveland everybody would have
understood everybody would have said hey
it's okay like dude you broke your neck
don't worry about it
and if I was proud of that then then
fine
I I would do it because I had hit my Max
but I felt like I had a little bit more
just a little bit more let's show up for
Cleveland let's make it happen come on
we got one more stop we gotta like don't
skip them over because I'm in Toronto so
we're pretty close yep so it's like okay
don't skip Cleveland just let's go let's
do one more and like we'll hit we'll hit
Toronto after there you go
yeah and I'm proud of that so all that
really matters is are you proud of you
you know not what other people say but
when you look at yourself in the mirror
are you proud of what you put in today
and if that means you need to lean on
gratitude one day and the other day the
next day you have to lean more into
working harder for your goals
um that's the inside game that everybody
needs to play but in general I think you
need to be much harder on yourself
because you're capable of more and you
need to push that just move the brake
line like wherever you would normally
give yourself a break
just move it a little bit
I don't don't like get all the way out
here it's just like just move it a
little bit it's an inch just yeah just
move it just move the brake line forward
just a little bit
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome for 10
more amazing rules from garyvee check
the video right there next to me I think
you'll love it continue to believe and
I'll see you there I sit on top of
almost 3 000 employees and two very
large businesses actively as the CEO and
then on the board of four others and
heavily invested in others and many
other things I'm involved with I have
plenty going on